il se trouve que je suis
constitutionnaliste comme vous le savez
également
je regrette un petit peu la mode
actuelle de vouloir inscrire dans la
constitution un petit peu tout et
n'importe quoi mais je dirais que
l'initiative me fait un petit peu
sourire parce que si on inscrit le droit
à l'eau dans la constitution sous
prétexte que nous avons tous besoin de
boire de l'eau chaque jour mais à ce
moment là pourquoi ne pas inscrire le
droit à la nourriture également et je
crois qu'on a besoin de manger tous les
jours donc il faudrait aussi l'inscrire
dans la constitution
mais au delà de l'inscription dans la
constitution il faut voir les
conséquences les conséquences bien
entendu c'est que le droit à quelques
choses deviendraient une créance des
différents individus sur l'état donc il
appartiendrait à l'état de fournir de
l'eau gratuitement ou plus ou moins
gratuitement aux citoyens et pourquoi
pas donc de la nourriture pendant qu'on
y est
[Musique]